wie schön du bist anastasia ich kann es
gar nicht erwarten endlich einzudringen
wir sitzen jetzt hier mit 50 shades of
grey jahre zu spät
wir reden mal über sex in büchern und
alles ist irgendwie nicht wirklich
interessant und dann habe ich gesagt
jetzt möchte ich mal dieses buch lesen
weil das ist definitiv ein buch in dem
sex vorkommen definitiv das eis in
meinem nabel schmilzt mir ist heiß er
als heiß heiß und kalt zugleich will ihn
in mir spüren jetzt sofort dieses buch
ist leider leider leider auch nicht das
was ich mir auch auf der von sex in
büchern muss sex überhaupt sein
in der literatur sex ist ein ausdruck
von sinnlichkeit und bücher
funktionieren über weite teile über
sinnlichkeit also die anbahnung von
sinnlichkeit aber die andauernd
geschildert es ist ja nichts was
ausgespart wird was stört ich hier an
dem 6 das was ja auch thema ist die frau
ist untergeordnet und muss funktionieren
und muss alles machen was der mann von
ihr verlangt und dann wird es mir auch
noch verkauft als sehnsucht in
zeitlupentempo stehe ich auf mein kleid
hängt an der tür des kleiderschranks
mein bh liegt daneben auf einem stuhl
aber wo ist mein häuschen wieso hat er
mir meint höschen nicht zurückgegeben
das ganze buch sollte eigentlich diesen
titel tragen wie so hat man muss hier
nicht zurückgegeben das wäre ein
wunderbarer titel für das ganze buch das
haben sich heute auch den kopf
zerbrochen über dieses buch die frau
lernt ihre sexualität kennen weil der
mann die an die hand nimmt und aus gehen
bringt und ich habe dann aber
tatsächlich noch gedacht an den weg
islam heißt er übersetzt unterwerfung
und woher weg sagt wir suchen eigentlich
danach uns etwas unterwerfen und hier
ist es nur sexuell hier ist gar nichts
philosophisches drin aber im grunde
genommen ist die sehnsucht nach über und
untergeordneten verhältnis offenbar noch
sehr stark sichtbar wo anna schreit er
während auch er erlösung findet und mich
fest umschlungen hält als dass ich mich
ärgere
das ist total schrecklich neben dir zu
sitzen
es gibt so viele schlimme szenen hier
drinnen endlos hühner erst wenn man die
gesetze laut liest wird einem klar wie
trivial die bilder auch sind es ist
sprachlich völlig uninspiriert das
stimme durchdringender blick ließ die
anwohner gereiht werden ohne ende
unsere erwartungshaltung ist jetzt in
punkto sex dann irgendwie nicht so
befriedigt und ich bin immer noch - wie
auch schon zu starten und sich den
schaden sehen wir die besten sex szenen
ich glaub nicht dass ich das als aufruf
starten will
gut dann starten wir das nicht als
aufruf